and yeah those are the tough decisions
sometimes we got to look at from the
standpoint like we cannot as a community
consistently tell them to quality
control and then when they do it see
why' you cancel that game that's a good
point we don't know what condition this
game was in we probably never know but
at the same time if they canel it and
they let something like red ball get out
the gate there's a good chance it
probably wasn't at their standard and
they don't want another red ball
happening absolutely it's sad we're
going to miss out a new on a new IP
right it's always sad when a new IP kind
of dies in in its incubation but